hello sir good to see you good to see
you guys
you're alive on the Rich Eisen show yeah
very good good to see are you gonna
crack that open yeah well I figured
we're gonna talk about Aaron Rodgers
level we are gonna do that and I will
get to that in a second but go go ahead
and finish up what you were saying did
you see did you see interrupt sorry no
no it's all good we're just talking
about LeBron go ahead so LeBron is
liking pictures on Instagram of Kyrie
and Lakers jerseys he's having dinner
tampering with he's not Russell
Westbrook and Anthony Davis and Kyrie
this week this is this league this is my
favorite part about the NBA is that we
somehow have gotten to a point where we
care more about dinners and Instagram
likes than the actual games that are
going on right like we're in that where
it's about to be the NBA final is he
gonna get a banana boat out I missed the
banana boat yeah well that's the whole
point though is he's allowed to that
this is just another version of the
banana boat him him dining with these
guys he could do that it's not a big
deal
Kyrie going to the Lakers would be a
hilarious hilarious move why because he
I mean the whole thing with Kyrie was
like I want to be out of LeBron shadow I
want my own team he does it fails but
not spectacular you know it did fail
spectacularly this year right and now he
goes to the Lakers is like hey I
actually like it with LeBron what about
you two guys is there is shadow
situation with you two guys
Illuminati yeah I don't know like that
that you that maybe one of you guys
feels that you're overshadowing the
other yeah I'm definitely overshadowing
a big cat is that right I talked about
this that's that's how you guys are fine
with each us no yes we just we just
basically anything that's good for one
is good for both yeah huh teamwork rich
why don't I turn it back on you you have
your own show you have your name on the
show because you're a narcissist all
this stuff yeah people are saying you
can't work you don't work well with
others I don't want to work with another
for exactly my teammate oh I'm fully
aware I am done with a to host show yeah
I'm still I'm sitting right here
you know what you are is you're a
producer in an on-air compadre right
here no no no no I'm I'm fully admitting
that SportsCenter that last SportsCenter
did is the last two host show I'm ever
gonna do yes did you have a problem with
it while you were doing it or was it
once you got a taste of the solo life
mr. bigshot you were like I'm never
going back to that once I got a taste of
the solo life mm-hm you get you're gonna
be like why don't you take half the show
no way yeah no I'm a control freak when
it comes to hosting a program and I am
NOT absolutely ashamed of admitting that
at all okay back to you guys yeah um you
know in terms of so when you're on a
rods jet yeah are you there - no I'm not
we don't we don't follow each other
around like we have we have personal
lives and since conception yeah we're
going to get the a rod thing is what's
up where did this come from
are you BFFs with it well I started
trolling him online and saying I worked
for his company like three years ago and
then it just ended up here with that you
know we you know PFT has other things
going on personally it's like you know
you get your solo albums but the band is
of the band right like that's when
people want to pay to see so you know we
tape a few shows they arrived it's not a
lot and every now and then there's
traveling component but when we're on
the jet like we didn't really Hank and I
just sat in the back we didn't really
talk to anyone okay
I'm not about to private jet life either
if it's up to me I fly coach I fly
coach's son that's what I said yeah I
like being with the people if it's up to
me I'm on spirit I'm on Southwest I
don't get a handle call out the gate I'm
not a first-class guy now granted I
think we're falling first-class today
they twist my arm and maybe first class
okay but under normal circumstances good
loose good use of latrine what about
middle seat what piano no I'm not a
middle seat guy no not a middle seat guy
because they you start doing the elbow
jive oh my gosh you're fighting for the
armrest I like to get the window seat
let me ask you this question are you
which one of you guys if one of the
other you are you a first on the plane
person or you can just chill out to the
last I always
I talked about the plane the air airline
travel decorum when it comes to getting
on a plane it is like every man for
themselves just jam yourself up in the
front no lines none of that stuff yeah
that's how it should be it's just you
cotton fun yeah yeah you do that just
like looking around and just like you're
staring at the board to see what the
flight number and everything in that way
you just hover around it's like a mosh
it's like a muddle huh yeah the minute
they started making you pay to put your
bag up top it changed the game you have
to get on the plane like early you have
to I like to get there I like to get on
the plane a little bit early yeah and
that way I kind of establish dominance
and then I do it when other people get
on the plane you see anyone that's
having a little bit of trouble putting
their bag overhead yeah you stand up and
you say hey let me help you that huge
everybody around you sees you and
they're like that guy's the Alpha he's
the guy has an incident I don't think he
knows how to fly right I believe that he
could convince himself to fly yes
interesting yeah yeah I don't have those
thoughts on a plane got you going this
yeah Richard just tweet at the airlines
yeah well well you know every time I do
that I'm tagging you now seriously it's
a big cut you know that help to people
with their bags you'll feel like a king
yeah just just to pay it forward like
that how exactly huh oh he's always
selfish it's just so that I feel good
about myself
can we go free-range here I got a lot a
lot I want to talk ok so let's take a
break ok you know I've got I've got
commercials that I got to do know I know
hey look these solo shows don't pay for
themselves you know I'm saying PFT
commenter in Barstow big cat finishing
up their grit week right here on the
Rich Eisen show don't go anywhere we're
back with more in a moment
all right great way to send us into our
Memorial Day weekend barstool big cat
and PFT commenter from the highly
popular show
pardon my take here you guys came in the
middle of the last segment I want to
describe the radio audience you bar
still you were in a bar stool hoodie
you're finding I don't want to get
yelled at your branding that's very good
and uh and you PFT you were you were in
a Jim Tomsula o t-shirt very well done
yeah well Jimbo Tomsula and and Chris
tell me correct me if I'm wrong in the
near five-year history of our show is
this the third pair of shorts that we've
had
yeah Dana Tomlinson came in one time
joints came in oh that must been a sight
yeah Hawaiian shirt and and Will Ferrell
came in
Will Ferrell had soccer shorts on very
high okay folks at home get like a
higher female demo I just want you to be
comfortable
okay that's one I'm always going so who
did you interview for a great week I saw
some men that yeah we had Sean McVeigh
we Sean we said some mean things about
Sean after the Superbowl so we we we
cleared that up we had Jared Goff and
Blake bortles mm-hmm Blake Griffin
mm-hmm Manny Pacquiao Manny Pacquiao
with him dr. Zac Efron did you he's got
a tweet back from Anna Kendrick yeah
now that's next level yeah where does
that rank it was very high up there
so was it better than the time that she
accidentally followed you when she
refold you back was that better
yeah the reef all back was better okay
well she followed me randomly on I think
was the night of the draft lottery and I
was like we're sitting in our office and
I said guys Anna Kendrick just followed
me you know when someone like that
polled you you're like okay they might
follow it might be like a Tyrese
situation where they fall a million
people like a Jose Bautista everyone's
fault so I initially went to her Twitter
I was like I got to make sure
I'm not getting batiste adhere yes she
only followed 300 people I was like this
is real I might have said it on our
podcast I also the draft lottery
happened the Bulls get the seventh pick
and I tweeted in profanities and all
caps for the next like three hours so
she opted in saw that and then quickly
opted out which is so much like the the
whole saying like it's better to have
loved to be that yeah completely like
wrong because I would rather never love
never be followed then followed a nun
followed but Zach Efron is a fan of our
show yes we went to his house and he was
able to FaceTime Anna Kendrick and
smooth it over mmm one thing we've also
learned is it's impossible to say so
we're at Zac Efron's house yeah not
sound like a jerk yeah your name okay
with that I'm a professional named Zach
I know where he lives
sure yeah he was a great guy I like Zach
a lot yeah it was crazy to find out that
he listened to the show
yeah so we walked in his house and he
heard her voice and he just like he lit
up and he was like I love those voices
so let me ask this rich you obviously
have had a very long career in in sports
media what was the first guy who came up
to you or woman who said I'm a fan of
yours and you're like whoa Don Mattingly
did it once that's a big one was for me
I mean that's yeah guy yeah Seinfeld oh
that's huge
that's huge that was the end of them but
there are those moments where you're
like wait you like what I do it's great
yeah cuz you be talking to a microphone
you have no idea what's listening or not
right
have you gotten that from Tomsula yeah I
don't think Tomsula
owns an iPhone no he seems like a tin
canyoneering kind of guy yeah but maybe
he's he's heard the pod have you reached
out I reached out so we got to Tomsula
we're trying to work our way in there
but it takes a long time for the carrier
pigeon to get back
so who's the pardon my take white whale
right now yeah I would say it's Aaron
Rodgers he's not been on he is not I was
well I don't know it's a mean thing I
don't know if accusing him
of cursing the box cuz he couldn't
finish his beer last night exactly what
happened I don't think that's the way to
both were they up and when when he
couldn't finish this beer and I think
they were did they win they did not okay
I rest my case
I can't not chug a beer in the state of
Wisconsin you can't that is that is that
is a felony in the state of Wisconsin
but he strikes me as a sipper when he
has passed when he has an alcoholic
beverage of choice it's it's a little
bit harder than than beer yeah so he he
doesn't he doesn't usually open the
gullet and throw it back I think you
should no matter what position you play
you should be able to chug the 40 faster
than you can run one yeah it is like my
bottom line on that and David Bakhtiari
I'm pretty sure he chugged at what two
seconds we had him on at the top of our
last hour and he was definitely over sir
nobody look Aaron did the the mistake of
sitting you got a stand
obviously gravity is your aunt gravity's
your friend it's the angle bhaktir I was
saying it's an angle it's an if you
gotta know the angles right and then
Christian Yelich and Matthew Stafford
and I mean yes staffer to did it in a
bar yeah I'm just glad the Sixers aren't
in because Chris Long on the sidelines
he would just blazed up entire bold you
take on that whole story what do you
mean the fact that that that he told Dan
Patrick that he smoked weed
yes scandal I mean huge skin good for
him do you smoke a right now early this
morning yeah yeah I did rich that's how
I do this show every day
Michigan is falling apart we got it I
knew you were trying to like filibuster
here but you just lost one of the best
coaches in college basketball and then
you're like well we'll just hire an old
player that's not just any old players
oh yeah using assistants so let me ask
you this question we have only two
minutes to the heart out Game of Thrones
you wasted ten years of your life on
that show
oh no no that we have our own only are
we have an app only segment so we're
gonna stay after class Oh guys I know
your flights not for another couple
hours we got you so all that said Juwan
Howard let me ask you how many Wisconsin
games is LeBron gonna show up - how many
- you know what helps his buzz it's all
about getting these macdonald was a
great coach well maybe he learned from
Buzz he's a great coach I understand
finding a buzz he's a great cop I
understand that but maybe if Juwan
doesn't have that ability just now the
buzz is gonna get the kids in asking the
question you just had one of the best
coaches in college basketball say Ann
Arbor is not the place for me I'm going
to Cleveland yikes actually what he said
is I'm taking the NBA opportunity that's
in front of me because I hate to change
hard was visited by three ghosts on
Christmas to go he is not going to give
that man an extension to go work for a
Michigan State er in the state of Ohio
and leave Ann Arbor is a tough find cut
to take that makes you feel better
is it Wisconsin under state or a man's
okay dating facts well by the way let me
just end this show right here your this
is fine dog you call me of the dad
sweater I've got one for you Oh since
you know that's a Rich Eisen dead
sweater for me this fits I don't know
it's lost the tag but it comes from the
heart what's this thing yeah thanks to
you guys for showing up we're gonna stay
after class and shotgun a beer here on
eyes and overtime we we wanna so I want
to thank Nate Boyer and David bakhtiari
have a great safe Memorial Day weekend
everybody thanks for taking in the show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app